surfing on the West Side we've got four
other people and we heard the lifeguards
Sirens going off making announcements
and then the beach got cleared either
side obviously knew something had gone
on heard the helicopters coming so
you're serious
unfortunately saw someone receiving CPR
here the lifeguards put up a screen so
no one can see but unfortunately from
where we were we could and then the jet
skis would go around the pier looking
for stuff
um so me and three other Surfers offered
to help we actually handled into the
pier to have a look they said there were
two people missing at the time and then
after about half hour they said uh
everyone was accounted for and that we
just we carried on